it's quite fitting that marilyn
vasivant's last name in french means
learned learning came easy to her
considering she has an iq of
228.
vossevant was born in st louis missouri
on august 11 1946 to immigrants from
germany and italy her parents never told
her she was exceptional she once said in
an interview no one really paid much
attention to me mostly because i was a
girl and i accepted that but the world
would pay attention in 1985 when she
topped the guinness book of world
records list as the smartest person in
the world she was nearly 40 when she
shot into the spotlight parade magazine
wrote a profile on her and readers had
so many questions for her that the
magazine offered her a sunday column ask
marilyn which exists to this day in this
column she ignited one of the fiercest
debates in probability of the 21st
century in 1990 a reader asked her the
following question suppose you're on a
game show and you're given the choice of
three doors behind one door is a car
behind the others goats you pick a door
say number one and the host who knows
what's behind the doors opens another
door say number three which has a goat
he says to you do you want to pick door
number two is it to your advantage to
switch your choice of doors this is
known as the monty hall problem named
after the former host of the game show
let's make a deal this is it behind door
number one or door number two or door
number three so would it be in your
interest to switch from door number one
to door number two i'll give you a few
seconds to think about it
most people assume that both doors are
equally likely to have the prize so they
don't see the benefit of switching
however vasevant replied yes you should
switch the first store has a one in
three chance of winning but the second
door has a two and three chance
she got so much heat for this response
and couldn't have imagined the backlash
that would follow she received thousands
of angry letters and said 90 of them
told her she was wrong scott smith who
has a phd from the university of florida
wrote there is enough mathematical
illiteracy in this country and we don't
need the world's highest iq propagating
more shame here's a letter from
professor robert sachs of george mason
university you blew it as a professional
mathematician i'm very concerned with
the general public's lack of
mathematical skills please help by
confessing your heir and in the future
being more careful don edwards of oregon
put it this way maybe women look at math
problems differently than men
but actually the people who sent her the
not so friendly letters were absolutely
wrong switching your door does increase
your probability of winning the prize
when you first choose door number one
there's a one in three chance that the
prize is behind that one and a two and
three chance that it's behind one of the
other two but then the host steps in and
gives you some help by opening up the
door they know is a loser so door number
two must have the rest of the chances it
went from having a one in three chance
to a two and three shot at the prize
since the host filtered out the bad door
for you door number three
switching doubles your odds of winning
or put another way so yeah take door
number two and
thank you for the extra 33.3
the outcry against vasavon was so
extreme that she felt compelled to
devote several other columns to
explaining her logic she noted that the
benefits of switching can be proven if
you were to play through the six games
that exhaust all possibilities this is
contingent on the host always opening a
door with a goat mapping out all the
possibilities shows there's a higher
chance of winning if you switch than if
you stay it's easier to understand the
problem if there are many more doors say
you chose one door out of a hundred the
host then eliminates 98 doors that they
know don't have a prize behind them that
leaves two doors the one you chose and
the only other one remaining do you
switch now absolutely when you first
picked you only had a 1 in 100 chance of
getting the right door the odds of it
being behind the other doors was 99 out
of 100 the host then filters out the
options for you by eliminating 98 bad
doors that they know don't have the
prize this is to your advantage because
it leaves the remaining door with the
rest of the odds a 99 out of 100 chance
of having the car
some eventually admitted they were in
the wrong a team at the massachusetts
institute of technology worked on the
problem and afterwards seth coulson of
mit admitted you are indeed correct my
colleagues at work had a ball with this
problem and i dare say that most of them
including me at first thought you were
wrong to which she responded thanks mit
i needed that as for that math professor
i mentioned earlier who sent that not so
friendly letter professor sax later
conceded after removing my foot from my
mouth i'm now eating humble pie i vowed
as penance to answer all the people who
wrote to castigate me it's been an
intense professional embarrassment
our biggest misconception is assuming
that two choices mean a 50 50 chance of
something happening this makes sense if
we don't have any other information if i
picked two people and asked who would
win a tennis match and you don't know
anything about them you have a 50 50
shot of getting it right but if i said
player a just took out the sport
yesterday and player b has won wimbledon
this would likely change your choice
information matters just like when the
game show host knew which door had a
goat they weren't opening up a door
randomly so the more you know the more
informed decisions you can make
vossevant once said people that we think
are very smart are not necessarily very
smart she explained they're more likely
to be educated or experienced rather
than intelligent what does she think is
holding people back from their
intellectual potential she's been
critical of compulsory schooling because
she says students learn passively they
sit there and are told what to believe
instead of learning to think
independently she went so far as to say
i would rather not see compulsory
schooling as for herself she never
graduated from university
dropping out of washington university in
st louis after two years to start a
career in investment before following
her real passion writing leading to her
famous answer to the problem that
stumped the world
there's another way to learn that
doesn't involve sitting in a classroom
brilliant is an online interactive
learning platform that helps you brush
up on your math science and computer
science skills speaking of the monty
hall problem my sponsor brilliant has an
entire course on probability which
explores misconceptions that can arise
including that famous brain teaser if
you're ever stuck don't worry you can
look at the explanation for more there's
something for everyone whether you're a
beginner or simply want to improve on
what you already know you can solve
puzzles with science through their
scientific thinking course one of my
all-time favorites is their logic course
which helps improve critical thinking
that forms the basis of mathematical
reasoning brilliant is free for you to
sign up by going to the custom link in
my description or pinned comment
brilliant.org newsthink the first 200
people to use my link will get 20 off
their premium membership which gives you
access to all of their courses thanks
for watching for newsthink i'm cindy
palm